Toxicity being done. Again, it's
all about dose response. Um,
this is,
this is important.
The dose response relationship is based
on observed data from experimental
animal human clinical
studies or cell studies. Uh,
it's based on observed data.
We're going to return to this because a
lot of what we talk about when we were
discussing risk and a risk numbers,
our extrapolations from observed data
knowing what is an actual data point
versus what it's an extrapolation is not a
small concern.
This is why dose response is so
crucial and essential and fundamental.
It establishes causality
that the chemical has
induced the observed effects.
Why am I emphasizing that so much?
Because in toxicology,
in risk assessment, on all of the
discussions that you hear about, um, uh,
environmental issues,
it is so often correlations.
You will hear an awful lot about
correlations. People will get, um,
uh, very certain and whipped
up about correlations.
Everybody in this room,
I'm sure,
knows the difference between
correlation and causality.
Without a dose response curve,
it is impossible as far as I know,
to determine causality. This is the
mechanism to determine causality.
Uh, even with dose response curves, yeah,
it's challenging, but that's
why dose response curves are so,
so important and establishes
the lowest dose, uh,
uh, that, uh, which the effect occurs. Um,
and this is going to be important when
we discuss thresholds and determines the
rate at which the, the, uh,
the injury builds up. Uh,
and the slope of the dose response
curve is going to be very important.
Okay.
This,
this graph is for responses
to the same dose. Okay?
So we're going to see dose response
curves that are going to have the changing
dose and responsive.
This is all to the same doubts.
So remembering that when we
talk about dose response curves,
we're talking about percentage response.
This is recognizing that at a particular
given dose that you're going to respond
to it differently than I
am, uh, differently than,
uh, than you are. That, um,
that there are going to be some people
that are particularly resistant,
uh, some people that are going
to be particularly susceptible.
And so you work for the FDA,
you worked for the EPA.
Who were you going to protect?
You've got to set these levels.
Are you going to protect these
folks? Well, if your Osha,
the occupational safety
and health administration,
well then you're looking
at healthy workers.
That's what historically these
levels have been, have been set for.
But do you want to protect
for the, the most, um,
uh, susceptible population? Do
you want to protect for infants?
Do you want to protect for compromised
individuals who may already have
pulmonary issues?
Do you want to protect for people who
may already have chemical sensitivity?
How do those policies play out?
If you protect for,
for the been part of this curve by
setting your, uh, your standards,
what does that mean economically?
What does that mean for commerce?
What does that mean? So these are, um,
practically pragmatic important questions.
All right,
this is your first dose response curve.
This is the dosage over
time and milligrams.
This is the response and percentages
of people responding to whatever the,
uh, the effect is that
you're measuring. You can
tie this to any particular
type of response.
You're going to have confidence
limits around here. Uh, as you'll see,
you'll have zero,
uh,
and we call that a threshold. Okay. Uh,
at what point does a,
do you actually see an effect?
Now remember,
only these are the data points.
You might think that to be
a trivial trivial point,
but the, again, the
ability, uh, and the, uh,
it's very common to extrapolate beyond
the data points because when we're
running tests,
I'm getting a little bit ahead of myself.
When we run these types of tests,
you need to have a data point.
You need to see an effect.
Sometimes you need to go to very high
doses in order to see any effect.
And so you'll have data points and they
lead to extrapolate back in order to set
a standard. Okay, we'll talk more about
that over the next couple of classes.
So you'll see over over
time increased dose you, uh,
we'll see a, uh, a curve.
This is the classic,
the classic s curve
for lethal dose.
LD 50 is perhaps the most common,
commonly used a data point. Uh, uh,
commonly used a standard by
which people made measure things,
the dose at which half
of the population dies.
Okay. Um, are there, it's,
it's mice or whatever kind
of, um, now say that you have,
so here the 50% level,
this is the dose that you,
uh,
that you're going to see lethality.
So when we look at LD 50s,
for different substances,
you have ethyl alcohol at a
10,000 milligrams per kilogram.
Uh, as you go down some of
your innocuous substances,
he got down to nicotine at
one milligram per kilogram.
Then you start getting into some of
the most toxic substances known, uh,
dioxin, the most toxic
synthetic substance, uh,
botulinum toxin,
a couple orders of magnitude more,
uh, more toxic. Just as a, as an aside,
Casper at in duels is the reference
that is largely considered the Bible of
toxicology if you ever want to
refer to it. Um, so you can see,
what do we have? One, two,
three, four, five, six,
79 c crossing better than 10 orders
of magnitude and in terms of toxicity.
All right.
So comparing two different shaped,
the, the shape of the, uh,
of the dose response curve is
going to be a important here.
You'll see a different thresholds.
The data points aren't outlined here,
but two different thresholds, uh, that,
that start before you start
seeing an effect. But the, this,
the shape and slope are
going to be important.
All right,
so here's two different toxicants.
Toxicant a toxicant be, uh, this is the,
the dose at which a 10% of the
population is responding. Here's the,
the, uh, the dose at
which 15%, 50% of the, uh,
uh, of the population is responding. You
can see the difference between the two.
So if we look at, uh, the distribution,
these become important because in many
cases you're going to want to know not
only the toxic dose,
but the effective dose.
Imagine what we're talking about
is a drug or pharmaceutical, right?
Um,
if you have a dose response curve for
the effective dose here and you're
measuring the, the ability for us, uh,
something for a drug to stop
headaches or whatever it is and the,
and the toxic knows to,
um,
that is going to kill you instantly,
right?
Then you're going to need to know the,
uh,
the,
the slope and the,
and the shape of these curves because
you're going to want to have the,
uh, the largest gap between
those, those two. Uh,
uh, those two curves. Why?
So the effective dose
for 50% of the population
is going to still be at a place where
there is no toxic effect, right?
But if you say, hmm, all right,
but if I want to get it
to 90% of the population,
then
it's going to be toxic for
what maybe 3% of the people.
Does that sound familiar when you're
watching the commercials for Dick's,
for different drugs and at the end of it,
they are talking really fast and
a listing off all of those people.
A very small percentage of the population
I'll go into and I won't even list off
some of the things that they say
on TV. It's just terrible. Uh,
so it's going to have all
of these wonderful things.
It's gonna make you happier.
It's gonna make you Tyler. It's gonna. Uh,
but a few people have
experienced Dah, Dah, Dah.
All of that comes from
dose response curves.
So take that and say, all right,
well that's good. I understand it.
For drugs, when you start
thinking about other substances,
all of the chemical substances that
we use every day in our, our society,
it's the same types of decisions
that, uh, that need to be made.
So if we were to just say,
all right,
well we found a substance
that, um, uh, that's used in,
in baby bottles and, um, uh,
knowing what the,
what the effective dose,
the performance versus the toxicity are,
those types of cost benefit questions
as simply part of the decision making
process and, uh, and regulation questions.
Okay. All right. So, um,
two dose response curves can
have very, very different, uh,
shapes and slopes.
So he starts saying that his,
uh, uh, again, the effect
of dose, We, uh, uh,
and the toxic dose here at a dose
of 20 milligrams per kilogram,
20% of the people are
going to be, uh, affected.
But up here at 40 milligrams, uh,
it's going to be effective or for 70%,
but the difference between here it's going
to be toxic for almost no one here is
going to be toxic for half of the
people that, that use it. Okay.
Two terms are going to need to know,
uh,
no way and low AOL,
no observed adverse effect level
low observed adverse effect level
crucial to understanding this and they
need to remember is that they are actual
data points.
Okay.
That becomes important because there can
be wide gat orders of magnitude gaps,
uh, and at different dose levels. Um,
so sometimes they're in human
clinical studies when it's things like
pharmaceuticals,
uh,
it's often experimental animal studies
when it's on things like, uh, uh, uh,
environmental issues.
No Al the highest data point at which
there was not an observed toxic or adverse
effect,
low oil.
The lowest data point at which there
was an observed adverse or toxic effect.
Let's take a look.
Okay,
so dose response curve here.
No effect,
no one response.
Actual data point.
This is your know AOL nodes or low al.
Uh,
the, the lowest point at which
there was an observed toxic effect.
Okay. Why is the, why are
these two data points? So, uh,
so important it's because these are the
points that are used as the called the
jumping off points for setting
standards by which you can be exposed to
something.
So
that's called the reference dose.
We'll reference dose is what you're
going to encounter often when you start
looking at what is considered
acceptable exposure to,
to something. Okay, we'll reference
dose. I mean they say, well,
I know that mercury is bad,
but what's the reference dose?
What is it that I can be exposed to?
Bisphenol a,
lead, whatever else. The
uh, the family, it's the
brominated flame at times.
What is the reference dose is going to
be the question for the reference dose is
what's considered an acceptable level
to be exposed to. And the way the, uh,
the reference dose is constructed
is by taking the no aal the,
the, the lowest level, which no
observed effect was seen, uh,
divided by uncertainty factors.
Okay.
So data point referenced
us not a data point,
okay?
So real empirical number
derived number, okay. Uh,
why is that crucial?
Important?
Because uncertainty factors and
these types of things can range.
I put 10 to a thousand.
I've seen even higher uncertainty
factors in that. So they'll say, well,
we know that we saw toxic effect at this,
but we're going to put it a thousand
or 10,000 times lower for it to be
acceptable because of
these uncertainty factors.
What are some of the uncertainty factors?
Most of the time you're not going
to have testing done on humans.
You'll have clinical trials for
pharmaceuticals for most everything else.
You're not going to
have that kind of data.
So that can be a factor of 10 because
you're going to extrapolate from animals
to humans. Differences in
humans, uh, susceptibility.
So healthy worker to infant.
Okay.
If we concerned about protecting
infants and we only have,
even if we do have human data,
unhealthy workers,
we're going to put an another factor in
a 10 adjustment factor for subchronic
data sources.
If you go,
if you're going from a sub chronic to
acute adjustment factor when the low
[inaudible] would, if you don't
have a no observed effect level.
So at every dosage you gave,
you saw an effect.
When you only have a low ale,
you put in another factor of 10 a
adjustment for when data complete,
which is very frequent, okay? Um,
because you're never going to have
all of the data, all of the tests.
So let's see, one, two, three,
four, five orders of magnitude.
Alright,
so this is,
this is what we're dealing
with with some of the
toxicological challenges. Um, um,
not only making policy setting standards,
but these are the fundamental handles
that we're going to use when we start
thinking about, okay, that's
what makes something toxic.
How are we going to
make something nontoxic?
practice green chemistry?
How are we going to design the
next generation of molecules?
All of these are the factors
that we're going to consider it.